yay Suzie's by the trees and the cherry
blossoms let the wind go through my hair
so guess what city I'm in Washington DC
our nation's capital it is the seat of
power for the United States of America
our country may be young but what a
history we have so join me as the Beast
checks out the beauty this is one of the
things I wanted to see our little cherry
blossoms remember I live miles above the
treeline I don't have trees and beyond
not having trees I don't have trees that
blossom and these are very picturesque
I mean how beautiful I don't have this
at home I have white but it's in the
form of snow they're so soft
it may seem like a silly thing to take
pictures of I don't have dirt I can't
grow regular flowers i am i have my
hydroponic garden that i'm working on
but it's not quite there yet something
as simple as this many people might just
say what what the heck is so interesting
about grass there is no grass there is
no soil in kavik the ecosystem is such
it's frozen ground you have the sphagnum
Moss layer and peat layer there's no
dirt and there's no grass I haven't seen
grass I haven't lived near grass at
least 20 years possibly 30 so that's a
unique tree oh that looks like a
magnolia but I've only seen purple ones
oh here these ones are kind of pink look
at little purple flowers little blue
ones
this is all liquid water and I betcha
it's not as cold as it is in the Artic
ocean you know or the kavik River at
home it's not really t-shirt weather
it's not thinking nothing is blooming
maybe the snowdrifts are finding new
ways to blossom and grow but that's
about it so this is a rare treat